[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I don't think this will come as a
surprise to anyone the war in Ukraine
growing tensions with an increasingly
belligerent China and constant threats
from regimes such as North Korea and
Iran have put the military industry back
in the spotlight the international arms
race is a fact here on visualpolitik we
have already told you about how
countries like Australia Poland Germany
and Japan are announcing sharp increases
in their military spending the list is
long however in order for so many
Western countries to re-arm at the same
time not only more money is needed but
also sufficient industrial and
technological capacity to be able to
manufacture and deliver all the
requested equipment in a timely manner
and keep in mind that although this may
seem obvious to us the truth is that it
is a real problem
we're talking about huge orders and
volumes to give you an idea in the
Fortnight from 15th of July to August 2
alone the US military industry finalized
contracts for almost 20 billion dollars
worth of arms and military equipment
sales to other countries in other words
Washington committed to arms sales at a
rate of more than one billion dollars a
day and of course this is just one
example High Mars F-35 Fighters missiles
Torpedoes howitzers tanks armored
vehicles practically the entire catalog
of U.S Conventional Weapons are selling
like hotcakes in other words their sales
have skyrocketed
the demand is off the charts among other
things it's because if the war in
Ukraine has shown anything it is that a
Western countries need stronger armies
and B American weapons are still the Top
Choice and that's by a long shot
the problem is that the production
capacity of the U.S military industry is
obviously not without its limits it
takes time to adapt an entire production
line to such a large and sudden demand
so of course all this in addition to the
efforts that the United States itself is
making to supply Ukraine with weapons
has a very clear drawback delivery times
Taiwan is buying U.S weapons but
Washington isn't delivering them this is
just one example but delivery delays and
endless waiting lists have become the
norm and then there is another problem
American weapons may be the creme de La
Creme but they're also terribly
expensive not only in terms of selling
price but also typically in terms of the
cost of using them these two factors are
pushing many countries to look for
Alternatives technologically advanced
Alternatives the problem is that there
are not so many options
foreign
but guess what right here is where a new
player is emerging check it out
Philippines to receive weapons equipment
from South Korea Egypt emerges as new
market for Korean arms exports
Holland South Korea saying multi-billion
arms contract the Philippines Egypt
Poland Norway Australia United Arab
Emirates Finland Estonia turkey no
matter which continent we are talking
about more and more countries are
turning their attention to South Korean
weapons in order to modernize or
supplement their Armed Forces it even
appears that Washington intends to
purchase tens of thousands of advanced
South Korean projectiles for the
Ukrainian artillery so the questions
seem clear why South Korea why are
countries such as Poland for example
betting so heavily on this Market is it
simply a question of timing or Price
what could all this mean for capitalist
South Korea
well in this video we're going to give
you all the clues as to why this country
is becoming a key player one of the new
Giants of the global Military industry
and believe me when I tell you that what
we are going to show in this video is
very likely to surprise you listen up
necessity
prevention
the South Korean military industry is
experiencing a huge boom an
unprecedented takeoff it is undoubtedly
entering its golden age South Korea
posed to become number four defense
exporter Korea was ranked ninth in terms
of the global defense export volume in
2021 according to key IET this year's
exports would push Korea up to Fourth
Place trailing defense powerhouses the
U.S Russia and France in other words
South Korea may have already surpassed
China itself specifically by the end of
2022 the South Koreans estimate they
will have finalized nearly 20 billion
dollars in arms export deals well above
the 15 billion Target set by the
government the question is is this a
one-off spike caused by the war in
Ukraine well if you believe that pay
close attention to these data
[Music]
according to cypri the Stockholm
International Peace Research Institute
South Korean defense exports increased
177 in the 2017-2021 five-year period
compared to the previous five-year
period and take note because this is the
highest growth rate of the military
industry worldwide this is almost three
times the progress of France which was
the country second on the list for
increasing its military exports the most
with a 59 increase over the same period
of time meanwhile other major exporters
such as China and the United Kingdom
reduce their sales by 31 and 41
respectively
[Music]
as you can see with these data in hand
it seems clear that the growth of the
South Korean military industry is not
the result of a temporary upturn but of
a very marked trend of course as you can
imagine achieving such growth in
military exports is not something that
can happen overnight
[Music]
behind all this data and all these
headlines lies a long road of
multi-million dollar Investments both
from large South Korean corporations and
from the state itself investments in
both capacity as well as research
development and innovation of course in
South Korea's case all these Investments
were not designed to boost military
exports as has been the case with other
Industries in the land of K-pop such as
for example automobiles no in this case
defense Investments were made primarily
with National Defense in mind and this
visualpolitic viewers is what makes the
South Korean military industry such a
special case
you see after the Armistice that
indefinitely halted the Korean war in
1953 the South Korean army was in Ruins
practically disarmed and exhausted Seoul
became almost exclusively dependent on
the United States for its defense for
this reason the South Koreans not only
welcomed tens of thousands of U.S troops
on their territory along with numerous
nuclear warheads but also became
preferred customers of the U.S military
industry and this was true for about two
decades the South Korean military was
set up operationally command and
Hardware wise as a sort of scaled down
reproduction of the US military itself
[Music]
not so fast however because in the 1970s
something was to happen that would
change everything in one Fell Swoop in
1969 the so-called Nixon Doctrine and
the opening up to China led to a massive
partial withdrawal of U.S troops from
Asia
give you an idea in the two years
between 1969 and 1971 alone the United
States went from having more than 727
000 troops stationed in Asia to having
only 284
000 South Korea's reduction was from 63
000 to 43 000 U.S troops in the same
time period and naturally put yourselves
in their shoes this could not be
reassuring for a country that remained
under the active threat from North Korea
we're talking about much higher levels
of harassment than today back then
Espionage violent coercion kidnappings
and assassination attempts by North
Korean Commandos while the order of the
day not to mention of course a gigantic
Army in numbers supported by the Soviet
Union
[Music]
in 1968 for example North Korea
attempted with a special forces Commando
to storm the blue house which until
recently was the official residence and
Office of the President in order to
assassinate the South Korean leader so
of course under the circumstances it is
not surprising that President Park
chung-hee said that this withdrawal was
a message to the South Korean people
that if there was another Invasion the
Americans would no longer rescue them
and all this despite the fact that the
South Koreans wanted to return the favor
to the United States for its help in the
Korean War by sending more than 312 000
troops to the Vietnam War to help Uncle
Sam
[Music]
Washington's withdrawal came as a blow
to Seoul South Korea became increasingly
fearful that if necessary Washington
would look the other way the alliance
with the United States was indispensable
but it was not enough by itself they had
to get down to work in order to get
themselves out of danger so what did
Seoul do well yes exactly what you're
thinking they took every last one they
could get out of their wallets and local
arms manufacturers started receiving
huge loans and tax breaks
[Applause]
[Music]
exactly the same thing happened with the
steel shipbuilding and electronics
Industries which were considered
strategic and benefited greatly from
this new policy you could say that South
Korea is one of those cases in which the
military industry contributed to the
Industrial Development of the country
a topic that by the way we touched on
relatively recently here on
visualpolitik I'll leave the link in the
description the point is that in this
way what happened is that little by
little the South Koreans went from
depending on supplies from the United
States to manufacturing a large part of
their own weapons it started with simple
things like U.S licensed rifles and then
upped the ante until they had one of the
most extensive and advanced catalogs of
weapons and equipment in the world but
wait a minute because obviously
visualpolitik is not a History Channel
but what can I say we couldn't talk
about what the new military industrial
giant is like now without some
explanation for how they got there so do
you want to know exactly what South
Korea's military industry has to offer
to the world why are more and more
countries making a firm commitment to
this new supplier well now let's take a
look
[Music]
the births of a military Giant
we saw it at the beginning of the video
Poland has recently signed multi-million
dollar contracts for the purchase of
armaments from South Korea we are
talking about nothing less than Warsaw
signing a whopping 14.7 billion with a
beat in new orders to the South Korean
military complex in 2022 alone and take
note because more money is on the way
and you know what this means it means
that what is set to be one of the
largest NATO armies in Europe if not the
largest of all will be largely and even
mainly equipped with South Korean
weapons Poland needed weapons to defend
itself and that is exactly what we are
providing we Koreans understand that
without weapons to defend ourselves the
end result is each tragedy Chun in boom
former Lieutenant General in the South
Korean army in total Poland will have 1
000 K2 black panther tanks 48 Kai fa 50
Fighters almost 700 K9 Thunder
self-propelled howitzers and 288 k239
chunmu multiple rocket launcher systems
in the coming years we'll tell you more
about that last one in a moment but the
question now is why is Poland going to
rebuild its Armed Forces with South
Korean weapons well there are four main
reasons for this the first of course is
the speed of delivery
give you an idea less than three months
after the purchase of K2 tanks and K9
self-propelled howitzers was signed
Poland was already receiving the first
shipment specifically the South Koreans
managed to deliver the first 10 K2 tanks
and 24 canine howitzers to Poland in
record time and why the big hurry
because among other things this allowed
Poland to continue supplying Ukraine
with Soviet equipment first delivery of
South Korean heavy weapons comes to
Poland the quick piece of this delivery
is of crucial importance in the face of
Russian aggression and the war in
Ukraine Polish president Andrei Duda but
how is it possible for South Korean
industry to have such fast delivery
times well this is basically possible
thanks to the fact that this country is
a huge industrial Powerhouse that also
has a very active military sector not
least because it is constantly producing
to meet the demand of the South Korean
Armed Forces itself
[Music]
another Advantage is their greater ease
of finding supplies to give an example
modern weapons are equipped with a lot
of very complex systems that need a huge
amount of chips and guess what South
Korea is the world's second largest
semiconductor producer just behind
Taiwan they basically turned themselves
into a One-Stop shop the South Korean
defense industry has strong and stable
ties with its suppliers including
semiconductor manufacturers that's the
advantage of having a large industrial
base you have easier access to all kinds
of components and supplies this is one
of the main reasons why Poland will
almost certainly be able to receive 180
korean-made K2 tanks and 212 canine
howitzers by the end of 2025 or early
2026 but wait a minute Josh didn't you
tell us before about 1 000 tanks and
almost 700 howitzers well yes well
spotted and here we come precisely to
the second reason why buying arms from
South Korea is much more attractive and
from other major exporters do you
understand what I mean well the South
Koreans are very flexible when it comes
to authorizing the manufacturer of their
weapons abroad through lice business is
business
unlike the United States which is very
restrictive in allowing its Advanced
military Technologies to be manufactured
outside the country the South Koreans
have no major problems with that issue
let's just say that their primary goal
is to win the contracts and so after the
deliveries of the tanks and howitzers
purchased by Poland that are
manufactured in Korea are completed it
will be the polls themselves who will
manufacture the more than 800 tanks and
almost 500 howitzers to complete the
rest of the contract in other words
these will be manufactured in Poland and
not in Korea now what are the advantages
of this well on the one hand for
countries interested in investing large
sums of money in defense it is much
easier to justify and more popular with
the public if the bulk of these weapons
are manufactured at home
in this way politicians can not only
push the point that they are modernizing
their weapons but they can also sell but
they are creating jobs in the country
and boosting the industrial base and
then on the other hand this also makes
it faster to complete the production of
the weapons since they are not depending
on a supplier in a distant country free
to produce them
so it's a win-win situation arms jobs
and an industrial base for the buyer and
profits for the seller sounds pretty
good right well if these two might
already seem reason enough to understand
the choices of countries such as Poland
the truth is that there is even more I'm
certain that many of you may be thinking
that one of the reasons that weighs the
most in the equation are the prices and
it is true South Korean weapons are
cheaper than those of other Western
countries
in fact this is another of its great
strengths yes many of the South Korean
weapons that are exporting well are
significantly cheaper than their direct
competitors for example take the case of
the canine self-propelled Howitzer from
the hanwar group you see two of its main
competitors in terms of performance and
capabilities are the French Caesar and
the German Panzer halbits 2000 all three
are technologically advanced howitzers
with similar performance and NATO
standard 155 millimeter caliber to give
you an idea of the competitive Advantage
the South Koreans have while a French
Caesar costs about 7.5 million dollars
and the German PCH 2000 costs up to 10
million dollars a canine Thunder costs
only four million less than half the
price of the German model and you may be
wondering so what's the catch well the
truth is that there isn't one it is
merely a question of cost and economies
of scale the Russian invasion of the
Crimea sparked a surge in demand with
Eastern Europe and Scandinavian Nations
now lining up to negotiate with hanwar
for its self-propelled artillery the
company is very competitive on price
history quickly the Korean government
accounted for about a quarter of
artillery demand so it has big economies
of scale the prices of its German
competitors are about twice as high Paul
Choi head of research at clsa Securities
Korea the South Korean military has a
heavy demand for artillery equipment and
supplies because the threat posed by
North Korea
it's meant that both the military and
manufacturers are constantly expanding
and upgrading their artillery equipment
to fire father and father and with
increasing accuracy against North Korean
ground targets for Germans for example
are the opposite their military is
hampered by years decades of a
disinvestment and their military
companies have much less local demand
which makes it more difficult to
maintain profitable production lines at
low prices by the way if you want to
know more about the sorry state of
Germany's Armed Forces not long though
we told you all about it in a video that
will also link for you in the
description but let's not get
sidetracked we told you before that
there were four major reasons and so far
we've only told you about three what's
the fourth one any ideas exactly just
the one you're imagining
[Music]
South Korean weapons have been
modernized and have reached levels of
sophistication and complexity that are
already not far behind many of the best
Us weapons for example although it is
far from the only equipment with a high
level of sophistication there is the
case of the k239 chunmu multiple rocket
launcher system those of you who support
us on patreon already know the many
details about this impressive system
because we told you about it in a recent
weekly snapshot bulletin the k239 chunmu
has been dubbed by military Specialists
as the closest alternative to the U.S
High Mars This equipment has become
incredibly popular since the war in
Ukraine and take note because the South
Korean one is about 20 percent cheaper
the chunmu is a multiple rocket launcher
system developed between the South
Korean Agency for defense development
and Han wild defense company
foreign
makes it possible to launch rockets of
different caliber explosiveness and
penetration in the same load thanks to
the fact that its launchers are divided
into two independent capsules it can
operate in saturation mode like a
Russian grad or in Precision mode like
the high Mars even in the same launch in
this way the same system can clear large
areas of the enemy line or destroy
specific targets with an accuracy of
less than 10 meters or 32 feet in
addition hanwar has developed a wide
range of missiles of various caliber and
range for this system with a single
charge it can fire up to 40 131
millimeter unguided Rockets with a range
of 36 kilometers or 22 miles in less
than one minute and if Precision is
desired it can also fire 12 239
millimeter guided rockets at a distance
of between 160 and 200 kilometers that's
100 to 124 miles a distance that they
hope to extend in the coming years
[Music]
and these are just a couple of the
options because the system is much more
versatile than high Mars when it comes
to choosing the type of rocket
[Music]
in addition hanwa continues to develop
new projectiles that can be used in the
chunmu these include the 600 millimeter
KT ssm-2 Precision missile which will
have a range of 300 kilometers which is
186 Miles when it is completed around
2030 it will become the direct
performance rival of the US Army
tactical missile system yes those same
missiles that Kiev is so insistently
asking Washington for and they may be
receiving them now for the time being
the k239 chin move is already
operational in the South Korean Armed
Forces has been exported to the United
Arab Emirates and has been sold to
Poland the latter country has finalized
a contract for 288 units at the cost of
reducing its high Mars orders which were
to be significantly delayed
so there you have it the South Korean
arms industry is experiencing a golden
era and the best thing is then this may
only be the beginning artillery Fighters
missiles tanks and keep in mind that
this could obviously have many
implications South Korea may not only
contribute to the rearmament of Western
countries but may also become a
formidable Fortress to be added to the
Allied Forces seeking to contain China
in the region the question is will South
Korea succeed in establishing itself as
one of the four or perhaps even three
largest arms exporters in the world will
we see any of these promising weapons
operating in more European countries you
can leave your opinion here Below in the
comments and remember if you like this
video don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe to our channel so
you don't miss any news once again thank
you so very much for being there all the
best see you next time
[Music]